alors une fois encore le soleil la joie
d'être ensemble la qualité des échanges
auront marqué la rentrée du Mouvement
Démocrate depuis 11 ans chaque année
porte en elle sont lot de souvenirs pour
les militants que nous sommes chaque
année est importante mais je crois que
cette année les particulièrement
alors rien n'aurait été possible comme
toujours sans l'engagement de toute une
équipe modeste par la taille mais grande
par l'abnégation et le talent alors je
voudrais les citer
[Applaudissements]
sous la houlette d'anne-caroline celui
de Delphine Fabien Philomena Florian
Franck François Gina Manon Martin Olivia
Hugo Virginie l'héliom Maximilien
Vincent Jacques Laurent et Pierre
[Applaudissements]
secondé par des bénévoles toujours
fidèles Jean-Baptiste
Ariane Quentin Catherine Jean-Loup
Charlie Morgane Paul Anna Laura Arthur
Tristan Victor merci à eux
[Applaudissements]
et puis les Jeunes Démocrates et leur
président augustote leur secrétaire
général Jules Pasquier dont je veux
saluer véritablement la qualité du
travail
nos amis de d'humeur et toute l'équipe
du site qui chaque année nous reçoit
avec tant de gentillesse et
professionnalisme
je veux aussi remercier les 120
personnalités qui nous ont fait le
plaisir et l'honneur de venir pour
participer à plus de 85 ateliers au
cours de ces trois jours
mais je voudrais également adresser mes
remerciements à vous tous
je sais l'investissement personnel que
représente la participation à notre
université particulièrement cette année
et vous voir ce week-end rassembler ici
si nombreux nous touche non seulement
mais aussi dit beaucoup de ce que nous
sommes une famille soudée et déterminée
à défendre ce pourquoi elle se bat
depuis un siècle l'existence d'un
courant central porté et préservé par
l'action résolu de François Bayrou
une famille qui défend un projet
singulier qui dépasse chacun d'entre
nous mais qui est rendu possible par
notre contribution à toutes et tous ce
projet de société ambitieux pour la
France au sein de l'Union européenne
face au déséquilibres du monde en
Ukraine en armée digne au Bélarus dans
l'Indo Pacifique en Afrique c'est
déséquilibre si bien analysé par
Jean-Louis bourlange Bernard Guetta
Jean-Yves Le Drian nous oblige nous
oblige parce que cette affirmation est
plus que nécessaire
en me rendant à qui est-ce il y a
quelques jours j'ai été bouleversée par
le courage des Ukrainiens
le courage et la détermination de celles
et ceux qui se battent pour quelque
chose qui les dépasse
leur liberté et à travers les leurs la
nôtre ne l'oublions jamais ces peuples
nous imposent d'être à la hauteur du
projet européen
au modem vous le savez nous sommes
viscéralement attachés au projet
européen et ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières années depuis 2017 et
particulièrement depuis 2019 avec cette
génération Marie-Pierre formidable de
personnalités qui enfin portent ce
projet européen au Parlement nous avons
de l'espoir parce que jamais nous
n'avons autant avancé sur le plan de
l'autonomie stratégique de la défense
sur la douloureuse question des
migrations elle a mis fin à sa naïveté
cher Marie-Pierre et sur le climat
l'Europe nous a montré la voix il faut
décupler nos efforts et le feed for
fifty-five nous montre le chemin
sur le volet climatique comme sur le
plan géopolitique aucun des défis
auxquels nous sommes confrontés nous
trouvera de solutions sans le
renforcement de notre capacité à agir
mais malgré cette évidence et les succès
majeurs de ces dernières années l'Union
subit une remise en cause intérieure en
Italie en Suède en Hongrie comme en
France les ingénieurs du chaos nous
expliquent que tous les problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
disparaîtrait miraculeusement sans
l'intégration européenne des
affabulateurs qui mentent et ont aimé
sœurs sur les doutes la défiance ce qui
promettent sans la moindre possibilité
qui n'advienne et abîme ainsi
profondément la démocratie
pour les combattre il nous faudra porter
cette responsabilité nous affirmer et je
connais votre détermination pour porter
haut cette ambition européenne qui
sous-tend l'engagement de chacun et de
chacun comme je connais votre énergie
pour d'autres combats qui nous attendent
des combats pour retisser le lien dans
un pays traversé par les doutes dont une
partie de la réponse et j'en suis
absolument convaincu passe par le fait
de cultiver ce que nous sommes le
courage la force des convictions
l'ancrage la proximité l'écoute avec
toujours l'humain au cœur de notre
action et cela vient de loin
ce que nos parlementaires réalisent
chaque jour en créant des ponts sous les
gîtes de Jean-Paul de Jean-Marie ils ont
démontré que le MoDem était un
révélateur d'intérêt général chez nos
partenaires comme dans certaines de nos
oppositions
et ce travail il n'est pas celui de
notre pas simplement celui de notre
président de nos ministres de nos élus
il est celui de tous les adhérents
en sillonnant la France pour aller à
votre rencontre j'ai l'immense privilège
de vous voir agir sur le terrain vous
engagez tendre la main rassembler
écouter
et à un moment où les fractures de tous
ordres continuent de grandir c'est bien
de cela dont nous avons besoin
ce que j'attends de vous c'est que vous
cultiviez ce que vous êtes pour faire
rayonner non seulement nos idées mais
aussi une certaine manière de concevoir
l'engagement au service des autres aimer
son territoire
identifier ses forces et ses faiblesses
rassembler partager un constat et
construire ensemble et réponses et nous
serons à vous coter pour vous y aider et
vous offrir le soutien nécessaire
il y a en chacun de nous ce matin cette
part de modem qui convient de faire
fructifier pas simplement pour notre ego
mais parce que toutes et toutes vous
détenez une partie de la réponse aux
besoins de notre pays alors je compte
sur vous nous comptons sur vous comme
vous savez pouvoir compter sur nous
notre soutien à cet engagement sans
faille les plus importants encore les
Français comptent sur vous je vous
remercie